zdf heute live herzlich willkommen der
ältestenrat bestimmt laut
geschäftsordnung des bundestages den
termin an dem sich der neu gewählte
bundestag zu seiner konstituierenden
sitzung zusammen findet und das ist in
diesem jahr der 26 oktober dieser
ältestenrat wird sich dabei ganz schön
umschauen denn das ist ein sehr sehr
junger bundestag den wir da gewählt
haben und darüber sprechen wir mit zwei
abgeordneten die ganz neu im parlament
sind schön dass sie bei uns heute abend
sind am ende dieser dass sie bei uns in
der sendung sind am ende dieser sehr
turbulenten woche jessica rosenthal
bundesvorsitzende der jusos r und
bundesamt bundestagsabgeordnete aus bonn
schönen guten abend und schön dass sie
da sind und maximilian merseburg
cdu-abgeordnete aus stuttgart auch bei
uns in der sendung bevor wir ins
gespräch kommen zeigt uns moritz neues
wird dieser neu gewählte bundestag sich
denn zusammensetzt
der neu gewählte bundestag so groß und
so jung war er noch nie mit 735
abgeordneten sitzen 26 mehr im parlament
als noch in der letzten wahlperiode rund
30 prozent sind 40 jahre oder jünger
davor waren es gerade einmal 15 prozent
grund dafür ist vor allem der zuwachs an
abgeordneten aus spd grünen und fdp so
sind beispielsweise mehr als 40 prozent
der grünen unter 40 bei der spd mehr als
30 prozent und bei der fdp sind noch
knapp 30 prozent unter 40 die grünen
emilia fester und niklas wagner sind mit
23 die jüngsten abgeordneten alexander
gauland afd ist mit 80 der älteste im
bundestag gefolgt vom dienstältesten
parlamentarier wolfgang schäuble mit 79
tv rosenthal sie fangen gerade erst an
wie lange wollen sie denn gerne bleiben
darüber mache ich mir um ehrlich zu sein
jetzt erst mal keine gedanken ich bin
erst mal wahnsinnig froh dass so viele
junge menschen und vor allem auch so
viele jusos ins parlament eingezogen
sind und ich glaube auch dass auch in
der politischen karriere irgendwann mal
ende sein muss wann das genau ist weiß
ich nicht grundsätzlich bin ich für eine
amtszeit begrenzung aber ich glaube das
muss man sehen ich fange jetzt gerade
erst mal an und nicht alleine sondern
mit 49 jesus zusammen
hamburg sie sind der jüngste abgeordnete
der unionsfraktion wie lange wollen sie
bleiben wollen sie einmal der älteste
abgeordnete der unionsfraktion werden
das stimmt nicht ganz ich bin der
drittjüngste abgeordnete der cdu csu
fraktion ich bin nur der jüngste der ein
direktmandat hier in stuttgart erringen
konnte philipp am tor und catharina dos
santos sind noch etwas jünger als ich
ich möchte jetzt erst mal die nächsten
vier jahre vollgas geben für meine
heimatstadt für stuttgart und die
interessen in berlin vertreten und
mandat ist immer mandat auf zeit in der
politik deswegen schauen wir mal wie es
weitergeht wie haben sie denn den
wahlabend und die letzten tage erlebt
können sie uns ein bisschen an die sind
an diesen turbulenten stunden und
letzten tagen teilhaben lassen fangen
sie gerne an herrn bersenbrück
ja also der wahlabend war natürlich
wirklich sehr sehr intensiv also bei mir
im wahlkreis gab es da einen dreikampf
der sich dann über den wahlabend zu dem
zweikampf entwickelt hatte am ende waren
es dann doch 3000 stimmen die ich vor
meiner mitkonkurrentin von den grünen
aber das ist natürlich eine sehr
aufregende zeit wenn man weiß wirklich
nicht bis zum ende reicht sogar reicht
es nicht dass es wirklich eine ganz ganz
ganz großer moment im leben und das war
dann wirklich auch die letzten paar tage
das erste mal als abgeordneter im
bundestag zu sein natürlich wirklich
sehr spannend ist ja bewegende zeit und
jetzt freue ich mich einfach auf die
aufgabe und hoffe dass ich da viel
bewirken kann in berlin frau rosenthal
wie war es für sie sie haben mir am
wahlabend lange um ihr direktmandat
gezittert am ende hat ganz knapp nicht
gereicht wie
war das für sie
also ich muss sagen es war sehr sehr
intensiv und meine blicke sind auch nur
ganz ganz selten nach berlin geschafft
weil ich einfach so stark auch mit
bohnen beschäftigt weil wir haben das
ist ganz ganz viel wahlkampf gemacht
auch mit viel unterstützung von der
partei und natürlich habe ich mir bis
zuletzt gewünscht dass es für das
direktmandat reicht 216 stimmen waren es
jetzt am ende mit die sozusagen nicht
erringen konnte und deshalb hat die
grünen-kandidatin gewonnen es ist dann
ärgerlich nur letzten endes bin ich
jetzt im bundestag und das ist jetzt
auftrag einerseits für bonn aber das
sage ich auch gleich so
bundesvorsitzende vor allem auch für
junge menschen dort wirksam zu sein und
darauf freue ich mich jetzt und ich bin
ja auch nicht alleine haben sie sich
denn eigentlich auch getroffen das ist
ja ein wahnsinnig großer bundestag ich
weiß sie haben sie sich zufällig gesehen
jetzt während dieser tage in berlin oder
ist man da total in seiner eigenen
fraktion geblieben oder hat man
irgendwie weil man festgestellt hat okay
wir sind auch neu irgendwie nochmal
besonderen kontakt zueinander gefunden
ich muss immer daran denken wenn wir
zwei gesprächspartner haben muss ich
direkt irgendeinen adressieren damit das
nicht passiert bei merseburg bitte
ja also wir kennen uns nicht rosenthal
vielleicht haben wir uns mal irgendwann
mal ganz kurz gesehen
sich ja vielleicht doch über den weg
aber bewusst auf jeden fall nicht aber
das sind jetzt noch vier jahre zeit frau
rosenthal sie waren sie haben eine sehr
große neue spd-fraktion die da gewählt
worden ist da hatten sie erst mal genug
zu tun sich untereinander kennen zu
lernen oder haben sie vielleicht auch
andere junge abgeordnete kennen gelernt
in dieser woche
wir haben tatsächlich vor allem erstmal
uns untereinander kennen gelernt
einerseits in der gesamten fraktion aber
natürlich auch mit den jusos da es fange
jetzt nicht bei null an sondern kennen
uns ja auch schon lange telefonieren
schon seit monaten von daher war das
jetzt auch vielfach ein wiedersehen
trotzdem mussten wir uns natürlich auch
erst mal wieder miteinander austauschen
auch über die letzten wahlkampf
erfahrung und über das was jetzt ansteht
was wir vorhaben das war sehr spannend
bleibt auch spannend und von daher war
der jetzt erst mal der blick nach innen
gerichtet ich bin aber sicher
insbesondere zb mit der grünen jugend
werden wieder auch enge verbindungen
knüpfen und man wird sich garantiert
auch fraktionsübergreifend mai begegnen
nun haben sie frau rosenthal gesagt sie
wollen einen anderen sound im bundestag
an stellen wie soll der sich anhören
er soll vor allem klarmachen dass wir
keine zeit zu verlieren haben
insbesondere mit blick auf unsere
generation
ich habe jetzt lehrerin die letzten
anderthalb jahre erlebt dass junge
menschen schülerinnen und schüler
auszubildende studierende einfach keine
stimme haben und wir sind jetzt da auch
um eben genau das zu ändern und das ist
das eine die ungeduld auch ganz klar zu
machen auch im bundestag selbst auf der
anderen seite aber natürlich auch die
lösungen zu präsentieren
und da kommt es am ende auf die
richtigen mehrheiten an und wenn alle
für fortschritt sind was man jetzt
zuhört dann bin ich optimistisch dass
wir den dann auch gerade mit sehr jungen
power die da jetzt versammelt es auch
hinkriegen
barbara man schreibt hier über facebook
ich bin froh dass sich der bundestag
verjüngt neue ansätze neue ideen zukunft
herr merseburg für welche neuen ideen
für welche zukunft stehen sie
naja also zunächst einmal denke ich die
diskussion in den letzten monaten war ja
eher eine in den medien vor allem
natürlich auch wo fridays for future und
solche themen ganz stark bei den jungen
im vordergrund standen jetzt ist aber
weil dieser bundestagswahl nicht die
grünen sind die stärkste kraft geworden
letztes mal waren es noch wir dieses mal
ist es die fdp für uns ist das natürlich
eher nicht so gut dass die andere
bürgerliche kraft in deutschland bei den
jungen menschen am stärksten ist aber es
zeigt doch ganz deutlich dass
zukunftsthemen eben nicht nur die themen
von frei dies für futures sind natürlich
wollen wir in den staaten klimaschutz
aber der weg den fall des für feature
gehen möchte nämlich klimaschutz durch
sozialismus im prinzip das ist nicht der
weg den wir gehen wollen und den ist es
auch nicht der weg den die meisten
jugendlichen gehen wollen die meisten
jungen erwachsenen gehen wollen und
deswegen glaube ich dass wir daran
arbeiten müssen das thema klimaschutz
genauso wie übrigens auch das thema
digitalisierung aber auch die zukunft
von arbeitsplätzen von wirtschaft hier
in deutschland zu schaffen indem wir auf
bewährte methoden setzen insbesondere
auf unsere soziale marktwirtschaft und
dann werden wir es auch schaffen wenn
wir die richtigen anreize setzen zb über
den co2 preis den ja die bundesregierung
bereits eingeführt hat und gleichzeitig
aber auch die nachhaltigkeit der
finanzen im blick behalten wir müssen an
der schwarzen null festhalten wir müssen
insbesondere vor allem die
schuldenbremse auch akzeptieren und wir
müssen die anerkennen wir müssen diese
schuldenbremse hoch halten und am ende
glaube ich auch dass wir über wenn wir
über nachhaltigkeit reden darüber reden
müssen dass die abgabenlast auf grund
dessen weil wir jetzt co2 preise
bekommen und auch diese steigen also
benzin teurer teurer wird dass die
insgesamt nicht steigen dafür haben in
deutschland bereits die zweithöchste
abgabenlast aller oecd länder mit 49
prozent für ein singlehaushalt ich
glaube nicht dass das nachhaltig ist
wenn wir da immer weiter an dieser
schraube drehen deswegen muss welche
regierung auch immer gebildet wird
darauf achten dass sie zum einen nicht
zu viel geld ausgibt also keine schulden
macht zum anderen auch nicht versucht
die wirtschaft und die bürgerinnen und
bürger auszupressen mit neuen steuern
und dann glaube ich dass wir mit der
anreiz steuerung zum beispiel bei einem
co2 preis aber auch natürlich
investitionen und investitionen in die
digitalisierung auch die themen der
zukunft anpacken können klimaschutz
durch sozialismus ist jetzt ratet dass
keine keine grünen keine
grünen-politiker hinrunde sind die
widersprechen können was sie sicher tun
würden sie können werde ich gerne an
träumen war hosen können sie tun gern
dankeschön ja also ich glaube du oder
das würde gerade ist ziemlich
eindrücklich beschrieben warum viele
junge menschen auch auf die cdu zu sogar
eigentlich keine lust mehr haben weil
sie das beschreiben des weiter so es
einfach nicht das ist was wir jetzt
brauchen wenn man so über beides for
future sprecher kann ich ehrlich gesagt
nur sagen da hat man irgendwie nicht
verstanden worum es geht weil das für
futures sich vor allem deshalb auf der
straße versammelt weil es zu langsam ist
weil die eben auch für unsere kinder die
ökologischen grundlagen sichern müssen
und ja wir als jusos wir sind jetzt auch
da um unter anderem auch diese gruppe
mit zu vertreten natürlich geht es dabei
nie darum eins zu eins genau das zu
machen was beides for future sagt oder
andere gruppen machen aber es geht doch
darum junge menschen zu hören es geht
darum jetzt nicht weiter auf der bremse
zu stehen wie wir das die letzten jahre
erlebt haben und deshalb finde ich es
sehr sehr schwierig an der stelle wieder
mal das fass aufzumachen dass man angst
davor verbreitet das alles nicht
bezahlbar ist haye politik muss jetzt
dafür sorgen dass dieser wandel
bezahlbar ist dass alle auch leisten
können was zu leisten ist um den
klimawandel aufzuhalten
niemand kann sich leisten dass wir das
nicht tun das wäre die katastrophe
und da kann ich nur sagen ist gerade die
frage von sozialen aspekten und
klimaschutz das gemeinsam genau das was
wir jetzt machen müssen dafür bin ich
jedenfalls im bundestag und da kann ich
definitiv schon mal sagen das nur jung
seien noch keine schnittmenge ist weil
mit dem gesagten eben werde ich mich auf
jeden fall nicht identifizieren sondern
ich möchte gerade für junge menschen
politik machen und die finden auch
klimaschutz mit als wichtigstes thema
und das sehe ich genauso und deshalb bin
ich jetzt auch im bundestag um das mit
zu vertreten da sie schon direkt was uns
sehr freut in die inhaltliche diskussion
reingegangen sind wollen wir gerade um
gemeinsames fundament zu haben uns
angucken michael ballack hat
zusammengetragen wie unterschiedlich die
positionen der parteien denn was die
inhalte angeht sind
während 30 prozent der
bundestagsabgeordneten
40 jahre und jünger sind sie ist bei den
wahlberechtigten auf den ersten blick
ähnlich aus auch hier sind knapp 30
prozent unter 40 rund die hälfte ist
zwischen 40 und 69 jahre alt rund 20
prozent ist 70 und älter
who 40 ist im neuen bundestag also
durchaus präsent dabei beteiligen sich
die jüngeren erfahrungsgemäß weniger an
bundestagswahlen 2017 lag der anteil bei
den unter 40 jährigen unter der
durchschnittlichen wahlbeteiligung von
76 2 prozent
die über 40 jährigen hingegen
beteiligten sich überdurchschnittlich an
der wahl für die bundestagswahl 20 21
liegen zu der wahlbeteiligung nach
altersgruppen noch keine genauen
statistiken vor
besonders ungleich ist übrigens das
geschlechterverhältnis im parlament
etwas mehr als die hälfte der deutschen
sind frauen im neuen bundestag ist ihr
anteil etwas gewachsen sie stellen aber
trotzdem nur gut ein drittel der
abgeordneten den größten frauenanteil
hat die fraktion der grünen den
kleinsten die afd
das waren jetzt sehr interessante zahlen
von michael wallrath und auch über den
punkt dass so viele junge leute gar
nicht wählen würde ich gerne im verlauf
der sendung auch noch mit ihnen beiden
sprechen vorher aber doch das stück über
das wir eigentlich gerade geredet haben
nämlich über die inhalte noch mal bitte
maike verlad diesmal mit den inhalten
alle bundestagsparteien außer der afd
bekennen sich zum paris vertrag und
wollen das 15 grad ziel erreichen die
union will die klimaneutralität bis
20.45 cdu und csu betonte im wahlkampf
immer wieder das zusammenspiel von
ökonomie und klimaschutz man wolle nicht
etwa auf verbote setzen wie die grünen
die ein tempolimit oder das ende der
verbrennungsmotoren fordern den
emissionshandel will die union stärken
europaweit ausbauen und entstehende
mehrbelastungen mit entlastungen in den
bereichen wohnen und mobilität
kompensieren zur frage des co2 preises
finden sich keine konkreten angaben cdu
und csu wollen den ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien forcieren
auch die spd will deutschland bis
spätestens 20 45 klimaneutral machen
klimaschutz sieht die partei auch als
jobmotor und soziale aufgabe beim co2
preis sollen menschen mit niedrigem
einkommen verschont werden strom soll
bis spätestens 20 40 vollständig aus
erneuerbaren energien kommen
berufliche ausbildung soll laut union
wieder gleichwertig werden zur
akademischen bildungsgängen das duale
studium soll ausgebaut werden das bafög
soll modernisiert und die
altersbeschränkung dafür gestrichen
werden
der spd ist die frühkindliche bildung
besonders wichtig jeder schüler und jede
schülerin soll einen internet zugang
sowie ein digitales endgerät bekommen
auch die spd will die altersgrenze beim
bafög aufheben das wort digitalisierung
ist an vielen stellen im unions
wahlprogramm zu hören etwa bei
gesundheit klimaschutz landwirtschaft
raumfahrt oder mobilität die
digitalisierung wird als instrument für
wohlstand gesehen
verwaltungsleistungen sollen
digitalisiert werden wir spätestens 20
24 sollen alle weißen internet flecken
beseitigt werden bis 2025 soll dann das
5 g mobilfunknetz flächendeckend in ganz
deutschland ausgebaut sein die spd hat
ihre vorschläge zur digitalisierung in
einem eigenen kapitel gebündelt unter
anderem findet sich darin ein größerer
fokus auf datenschutz als bei der union
die forderungen nach einem sozialtarif
für den netzzugang und zwar für bürger
mit geringem einkommen für schüler und
studierende und die forderung nach
schnell im internet für alle haushalte
und unternehmen und zwar mit einer
bandbreite von mindestens einem gigabit
pro sekunde
wenn man sich die programme so anguckt
dann könnte man sagen auch eine große
koalition würde doch eigentlich
inhaltlich könnte man das doch
hinbekommen wenn man sich sie beide
anhört würde ich sagen geht nicht oder
was sagen sie
also ich glaube die große koalition ist
in beiden parteien vermutlich im moment
nicht das attraktivste und das
beliebteste der regierung ich glaube
auch dass das für die demokratie an sich
nicht unbedingt das beste ist wenn die
beiden größten parteien die eigentlich
die linke und die rechte mitte der
gesellschaft repräsentieren sollen immer
wieder gemeinsam koalieren und deswegen
glaube ich schon auch dass es besser
wäre wenn wir jetzt nicht darauf den
fokus setzen die große koalition zu
machen aber für uns als union ist ganz
klar wir sind eine partei die als
christdemokratische partei natürlich das
thema verantwortung als eigentlich den
zentralen politikbereich hat wir wollen
verantwortung übernehmen wir wollen auch
verantwortung übernehmen für unser land
und deswegen werden wir als union immer
regierungs bereit sein wir werden immer
bereit seien zu gesprächen und wir
werden nicht sagen nein wir hauen ab in
die opposition um jeden preis weil wir
einfach verantwortung für dieses land
tragen das ist ganz wichtig ich glaube
aber nicht dass es zu einer großen
koalition kommen wird und ich glaube
auch dass es in den inhalten wenn wir
uns jetzt darüber sprechen wollen uns
für die zukunft aufzustellen und nicht
eben die letzten acht jahre zu
aufzuarbeiten dann ist das glaube ich
auch gar nicht so passend und ich glaube
wie gesagt wir müssen jetzt in die
zukunft denken und deswegen glaube ich
dass es da andere koalition geben wird
aber im moment sind sowieso andere am
drücker was das angeht
frau rosenthal sie haben als jusos fiel
am spd-programm mitgeschrieben viele
ihrer forderungen sind damit drin zum
beispiel eine ausbildungsplatzgarantie
eine kindergrundsicherung was davon
werden sie jetzt im bundestag umsetzen
können
ich würde erstmal gerne noch
unterstreichen wollen dass es eben diese
gemeinsamkeiten wie das jetzt im beitrag
irgendwie rübergekommen ist in der form
ehrlich gesagt überhaupt nicht gibt wir
wollen an vielen stellen ganz andere
punkte wollen viel weiter gehen wie zb
mit der ausbildungsplatzgarantie wie zb
auch damit dass wieder nicht beim bafög
nicht nur die altersgrenze fallen lassen
wollen sondern dass wir wollen dass es
ein vollzuschuss wird das heißt
studierende müssen es nicht mehr
zurückzahlen all diese punkte sind viel
weitreichender als das was die union
will und von daher ist die große
koalition auf jeden fall vom tisch wenn
wir jetzt darüber sprechen was es
eigentlich entscheidend und zentral wenn
wenn es zu diesen
koalitionsverhandlungen kommt dann ist
es natürlich so dass wir auch als jusos
die punkte die wir im zukunftsprogramm
aufgeschrieben haben wie die ausbildung
garantie wie investitionen in bildung
wie die frage dass jeder ein endgerät
bekommt jede schülerinnen und schüler
all diese punkte natürlich jetzt auch im
koalitionsvertrag sehen wollen nur erst
mal sind wir jetzt in der phase das
überhaupt gespräche geführt werden erste
annäherungsversuche
vertrauensverhältnis aufgebaut werden
und dann am ende des tages im
koalitionsvertrag verhandelt wird und da
ist klar da wollen wir jusos am tisch
sitzen und da werden uns auch inhaltlich
stark einbringen im fokus steht für uns
vor allem wenn wir über fortschritt
reden der soziale fortschritt das dürfte
klar sein weil sie jetzt beide das wort
koalition so oft verwendet haben haken
wir dieses thema mal ab würde ich sagen
wir gucken mal frau rosenthal sie haben
getwittert 111 ii von sich
vielleicht können wir gerade mal hier
auf den bildschirm schalten genau und da
sehen wir dass alfie das erinnert uns
natürlich maximal an dass alfie dass die
parteivorsitzenden von grünen und fdp
diese woche getwittert haben wir auch
der text kommt uns bekannt vor auf der
suche nach einer neuen regierung loten
wir gemeinsamkeiten und brücken aus und
finden viele spannende zeiten hier sehen
wir sie mit den beiden vorsitzenden der
jugendorganisation der grünen frau
rosenthal das heißt ihre koalition steht
quasi schon fest fehlt eigentlich nur
noch die fdp auf dem bild oder
ja das könnte man auf jeden fall so
meinen ich glaube was für uns einfach
wichtig ist und was glaube ich aber auch
ehrlich gesagt niemanden überraschen
sollte die die beiden programme mal
übereinander legen dass gerade der
schulterschluss zwischen spd und grünen
relativ klar ist gerade mit der grünen
jugend arbeiten wir vertrauensvoll super
eng zusammen als jusos wir haben ganz
ganz viele inhaltliche schnittmengen von
daher sind da glaube ich die bande fest
geknüpft
selbstverständlich werden wir auch auf
der jugend politischen ebene mit mit der
fdp noch sprechen jedenfalls habe ich
das vor aber die inhaltlichen
schnittmengen die es vor allem zwischen
grüner jugend und jusos sehr sehr sehr
sehr klar herr merseburg würden sie sich
wünschen dass armin laschet der nächste
kanzler der bundesrepublik ist
wenn es die möglichkeit gibt eine links
geführte regierung in deutschland zu
verhindern dann finde ich das natürlich
super und wenn er mit laschet erschafft
mit grünen und
der fdp noch eine regierung zu bilden
dann glaube ich ist das gut für das land
weil ich glaube einfach dass eine
spd-geführte regierung in der krise wie
wir es gerade stecken ich glaube die
wirtschaft braucht nach corona ganz
dringend erholung wenn wir die themen
digitalisierung und klimawandel schaffen
wollen dann werden wir das nicht wie wir
das jetzt vorher gehört haben gegen die
wirtschaft schaffen sondern nur mit der
wirtschaft deswegen glaube ich ist es
ganz wichtig für das land welche
regierung wir bekommen und ich glaube
natürlich mit armin laschet würde das
besser funktionieren aber auch klar ist
dass wir von den wählern nicht den
auftrag bekommen haben jetzt als
allererste die regierungsgespräche zu
führen sondern das sind jetzt
tatsächlich andere erst mal am drücker
wir müssen kleine brötchen backen aber
ich habe es vorher schon gesagt wir
stehen als union immer bereit für eine
regierungsbeteiligung weil wir eine
partei der verantwortung sind und
verantwortung für unser land übernehmen
wollen frau rosenthal sie haben schwer
geatmet ich konnte es hören
ja ich muss einfach sagen
wenn ich auf die umfragen schauen wenn
man sich jetzt auch noch mal anguckt
welche zustimmungswerte olaf scholz auch
nach der wahl wieder hat welche
zustimmungswerte auch die region eine
mögliche ampelkoalition hat dann würde
ich wirklich darum bitten dass die roten
socken die aus der siebten etage des
kellers der union irgendwie hoch
gebracht worden jetzt endlich wieder da
hin zurück gebracht werden es geht
einfach an der realität vorbei immer
wieder den untergang des abendlandes und
irgendwelche linksbündnisse die das
fokussieren würden nach vorne zu stellen
weil das einfach nichts mit der
verantwortung zu tun hat die jetzt vor
uns liegt die gerade auch mit blick auf
die junge generation vor uns stimmt da
da vor uns liegt wenn wir uns anschauen
wie auch armut entwicklungen sind das
mit aus corona gefolgt es sich meines
lehrerin kann ich sagen schülerinnen und
schüler eltern die warten jetzt darauf
dass endlich auch mal politik gemacht
wird für diese gruppen und deshalb ist
jetzt zeit über inhalte zu sprechen und
die roten socken im keller zurück zu
packen also ich sehe sie beide haben
sich viel zu erzählen wenn sie sich in
der bundestags kantine treffen ich
wünsche ihnen einen regen politischen
austausch auch gerne miteinander über
parteigrenzen hinweg vielen dank jessica
rosenthal und maximilian merseburg dass
sie bei uns heute abend in der sendung
waren vielen dank und alles gute für
ihren start im neuen deutschen bundestag
[Musik]
ja und damit gehen wir ein bisschen
weiter in die analyse und das tun wir
gemeinsam mit professor doktor christian
breunig er ist politikwissenschaftler an
der universität in konstanz schönen
guten abend herr professor bräunig das
war ja eine auch inhaltlich schon sehr
muntere auseinandersetzung der wahlkampf
ist vorbei aber da ist schon der
politische gestaltungswille erkennbar
wie interpretieren sie denn die neue
zusammensetzung des neuen bundestages
also ich glaube man hat ganz schön
gesehen dass neue leute wie auch im
arbeitsumfeld neue themen neue ideen
mitbringen aber genauso ist auch im
arbeitsumfeld dass meine neues umfeld
kommt man sich dran gewöhnen muss man
kommt ein parlament mal kommt den
ausschüsse man muss von den news zu der
spd über wechseln und das gibt dann auch
wieder reibungspunkte um die spannende
frage dabei ist natürlich kann ich meine
eigenen ideen mitbringen oder muss ich
mich über zeit den gepflogenheiten der
institutionen dann anpassen genau in
diese richtung geht die frage eines
users namens stephen über youtube der
fragt sehen sie es als spagat die
fraktion mit neuen denkansätzen zu
modernisieren und gleichzeitig für
attraktivere posten innerhalb der
fraktion in den wichtigen ausschüssen
den alten zu gefallen
genau das ist dass das schöne daran dass
wenn man mit neuem personal kommt denen
auch neuen aufgaben zuweisen kann und
die aufgaben dann aber auch oft schon
den präferenzen den einzelnen
abgeordneten entsprechen also man hat ja
gesehen frau rosenthal wasser in der
bildungspolitik interessiert deswegen
gibt es mich natürlich in ausschüsse wie
im bildungsausschuss laufen
interessieren uns so muss man
zusammenspielt finden zwischen den
eigenen interessen und den
parteiinteressen und das ist natürlich
verhandlungspausen ist ein schwieriger
spagat
er kann natürlich wenn man auf einer
erfolgswelle reitet einfache gelingen
als wenn man verluste waren
nun hat man aber vielleicht gerade als
junger abgeordneter als junge
abgeordnete themen die in der breite gar
nicht so sehr interessieren die eben vor
allem junge wähler interessieren aber
mit denen man sich in der fraktion
keinen namen und kein amt und keinen
renault mehr arbeiten kann wie schafft
man das sein eigenes thema durchzusetzen
um gleichzeitig sichtbar zu werden und
auch karriere zu machen denn auch das
wollen natürlich viele
genau und das ist so der die dass die
spieler einige schwierige sache was
glaube ich an dieser wahl ganz besonders
ist und was so noch nicht vorgekommen
ist ist das ein riesen überschneidungen
gibt zwischen was junge wähler wollen
was junge abgeordnete wollen und was
tatsächlich die drückenden probleme der
gesellschaft hin also wir haben alle
schon viel von klimapolitik gehört dass
die grünen sehr gut bedienen die titel
digitalisierungs politik ist das andere
große themen feld wo sich fdp und cdu
herr forderungen also ich glaube hier
besteht diesmal mit dem neuen bund
hatten wirklich nur außerordentlich und
seltene
chance sie beschäftigen sich ja in ihrer
forschung damit welche auswirkungen der
background von politiker innen auch auf
ihre tätigkeit hat was lässt sich aus
den erkenntnissen die sie haben
schließen für diesen neuen bundestag
daraus lässt sich schließen dass eben
die abgeordneten erst mal ihre themen
mitbringen wie versuchen umzusetzen aber
durch die anreizstrukturen die an die
parteien geben weil man sich eigene
karrierechancen aufbauen will nimmt man
sich dann im laufe der zeit meint ihn
also es kann ja auch in dem einspieler
die digitalisierung die klima und die
bildungspolitik
tatsächlich ist viel politik aber über
wirtschaft und sozialpolitik also meine
erwartung wäre dass hamburg und zwei
rosenthal sich da in diese richtung hin
in den nächsten legislaturperiode
anpassen würden nun schauen wir uns mal
an wie denn die bundestagswahl aussieht
wenn wir uns die altersgruppen
aufschlüsseln dann ist natürlich
interessant zu sehen welche themen
interessieren gerade die jungen das sind
themen wie bildung klimaschutz natürlich
und dann ist interessant zu sehen wer
sich für welche partei entscheidet und
da sehen wir hier auf unsere zdf heute
seite kann man diese interaktive grafik
sich selber auch noch mal angucken so
wie viele andere grafiken auch und da
sehen wir zum beispiel bei der union
die erst wähler also hier die
altersgruppe der 18 bis 29 jährigen elf
prozent gerade mal 11 prozent der
erstwähler entscheiden sich für die
union wir sehen bei der letzten wahl
2017 waren es noch 25 prozent was auch
nicht viel ist aber natürlich schon sehr
viel mehr als jetzt die elf und wenn wir
dann gleichzeitig gucken was bei der fdp
und den grünen los ist dann sehen wir
bei den grünen erst wähler 22 und bei
der fdp 19
woran liegt das herr professor breunig
dass offenbar die fdp und die grünen die
jungen so gut abholen und die cdu/csu
offenbar gar nicht
ja das spannende natürlich ist für die
neuen wähler die müssen an parteien
gebunden werden und über themen kann man
wähler an parteien sind bei der grünen
partei ist natürlich das klima thema das
thema das neue wähler wild mit bei der
fdp scheint ja dass ein bisschen breit
hat gefasst aber ich glaube themen wie
eigenverantwortung
digitalisierung wahrnehmen auch themen
die viele junge leute gesagt haben ich
wähle die
fdp dieses mal auf der anderen seite ist
natürlich so junge wähler denken noch
nicht so viel über renten nach und
wahrscheinlich gewinnt man dadurch die
mit den klassischen geben der spd und
den klassischen dem der großen parteien
eben keinen neuen und jubel was ist denn
mit der optik die fdp hat eine kampagne
mit magenta
slogans die ins auge gesprungen sind
schwarz weiß fotos von christian lindner
das wahlprogramm der fdp sah aus wie
eine hochglanzbroschüre im vergleich zu
dem der union dass er eher aus wie eine
gebrauchsanweisung für einen staubsauger
von der optik her wie wie
ausschlaggebend ist dass und wie viel
wird dann auch am ende vielleicht über
oberflächlichkeit entschieden
ich glaube überhaupt
also die meisten wähler
entscheiden sich relativ früh für eine
partei und ich glaube auch viele junge
wähler haben dieses mal genau auf die
inhalte geguckt die wollten einen
politischen wechsel haben weil es eben
viele dringende probleme in der
gesellschaft gibt und da spielt die
farbe des parteitags überhaupt keine
rolle
ein kommentar von burkhard hecht über
facebook der sagt die jungen heißt nicht
besser gibt es
fehler die junge abgeordnete machen ist
das vielleicht die staaten mit sehr viel
ambitionen und sehr viel idealismus und
landen dann sehr schnell sehr hart oder
gibt es da wege wie man wie man gut
einen guten start hinlegen kann
es ist auf jeden fall ein sehr hartes
geschäft das bonner geschäft und daran
müssen sich die abgeordneten gewöhnen an
was man auch sagen kann oder sieht in
den daten das nach zwei drei
legislaturperioden doch einige wieder
aus der politik aussteigen sich anderen
aufgaben
widmen aber
fehler machen macht man über also ich
glaube das ist nicht das problem dass
man fehler macht sondern dass man guckt
wie man verbindungen schafft wie man
neue politik gestaltet und das ist eine
tolle aufgabe und ich glaube darüber
liegen uns nur abgeordneten auch
anerkennung dass man bevor wir am ende
noch mal ein bisschen in die zukunft
blicken was die personellen
aufstellungen für kanzlerkandidaten
angeht noch eine frage was bedeutet die
zusammensetzung dieses parlaments für
die politik der kommenden vier jahre
ich glaube eben
so wie jetzt kann mich
ja also ich glaube die wichtigen themen
wurden ja schon im wahlkampf
angesprochen und die große
herausforderung ich glaube der nächsten
legislaturperiode ist einfach dass es
viele verschiedene themen gibt es gibt
nicht nur die carola krise es gibt nicht
nur arbeitslosigkeit es stehen einfach
sehr viele verschiedene probleme an und
diese einigermaßen möchten bundestag
durch zu bekommen das uns die kollektive
herausforderung der jungen als auch
schon der erfahrenen abgeordneten nun
finden ja was die regierungsbildung
angeht viele gespräche statt an den in
den kommenden tagen teenie erfragt über
youtube frage an den professor was
denken sie über das persönliche
verhältnis von laschet und lindner ist
es wahrscheinlich dass beide eine
jamaika-koalition erzwingen werden
können
das ist eine spekulation
ich weiß ich kenne ihr persönliches
verhältnis nicht ich kenne sie nicht
persönlich deswegen fällt mir schwer
eine gute antwort zu geben
aber ich denke das wichtige wird diesmal
doch tatsächlich über die inhalte
passieren und die koalitionsregierung
sind deshalb umso wichtiger dann sind
wir gespannt was am ende rauskommt
professor breunig vielen dank dass sie
bei uns mit ihren einschätzungen im
studio und in der sendung waren und
vielen dank an sie zu hause fürs
mitmachen und mit kommentieren und einen
schönen abend noch und bis zum nächsten
mal